they really did nail the right time of
year to release this so yeah I had been
working my way through daredevil season
three and all of a sudden got feelers oh
hey look at that castlevania season
two's out and I put daredevil on hold it
immediately burned through this in two
settings so I am still gonna do
daredevil season three I'm enjoying it
so far we'll see if it completely falls
apart in the second half as so many of
the Marvel Netflix shows do in any case
we're not gonna talk about that right
now I'll get to that probably later this
week let's talk Castlevania oh I love
this oh so good this is really does just
it delivers exactly what I would want
out of this it delivers vampire hunter D
bloodlust style visuals wrapped around
the insanity that is Castlevania in
terms of you know how much of a badass
Dracula is in terms of how sort of
beating down the heroes of these things
tend to be in terms of how crazy the
castle is but it still it delivers all
that but at the same time still only
feels like it's scratching the surface
one of the actors has said they're
getting a season 3 we'll see I don't
think Netflix has officially confirmed
but I hope so so this is in many ways a
very significant improvement from the
first season which I also liked very
much but the first season was very
obviously built basically as a prequels
the wrong but I'd like a set up movie
that had been chopped into four pieces
it wasn't built as a show now this
second season it feels much more
properly developed as a show
it still doesn't have
not every episode feels as satisfying as
others do sometimes they end in slightly
weird places or you get through you
realize oh there was kind of no action
this episode so it is still telling an
overall story broken into in this case
eight parts instead of four but it does
not feel as much of the the cutoff
points for each episode don't feel as
arbitrary and certainly not yet happen
that doesn't happen as much as happened
in the first season it's like this maybe
wants to try selves like Oh little odd
place to end but for the most part they
they're really they feel like much more
satisfying pieces but it is very much
built to lead directly into the episode
it's built to be benched which is
something that can go either way for me
when we're talking about our long shows
13 episodes or more that's exhausting
for me but you're talking half-hour
episodes and only eight episodes and
yeah I will pinch that happily and it
did so I mean I just love this animation
style it is not the highest quality
animation you will find that it's not
the smoothness you can you know as with
a lot of anime style stuff you can tell
it that it's a little bit jagged from
post to post except for like the really
high end action where it's very obvious
they up the frame count on these things
so there is that but at the same time
like I'm used to that with this style of
animation so it certainly doesn't bother
me at all
I like a significant dove wish we had a
slightly greater variety to the monsters
cuz if you play the Castlevania games
one of the great things about them
especially like starting with Symphony
of the Night which really went nuts with
this is that basic Dracula's castle is
basically a repository of every monster
from everywhere every mythology ever and
it allows for a lot of creature variety
and while I do like all the stuff that
we get and it's it is still nicely
varied I wish that we had gotten some
more like far end bizarre extremes but
I'd use I do still I still like the feel
of it it's still a feel
that's they get the feel of this really
well and especially in some of the
action scenes they they do a
surprisingly good job of capturing the
feel of combat from the Castlevania
games as well like what some of them
would like I'm not sure how many of them
cuz I haven't played every Castlevania
game but from the ones that I have
played there's some things that out for
some of some of the things the heroes do
were pulled directly from the games and
I'm watching it going oh that is so cool
getting to watch him do that and there
were other things that even though I
don't know if they were pulled directly
from the games with some of the things
that the heroes do in the middle of
combat it all feels very Castlevania and
it's just oh that's so satisfying I
don't want to I am problem a lot of my
gushing is gonna be for the action the
action is kind of a Highland the
second-to-last episode especially that
is all the things gold when when the
heroes dude the proper assault on
Dracula's castle and actually come face
to face with Dracula himself those those
action scenes those fight scenes oh man
they're so good cuz they had a lot of
work to do because there have been a lot
of buildup over the course of the show
you know showing you how dangerous these
vampires are cuz Drake is not the only
event he's got a basically an army
vampires and by the time the the heroes
get to the castle they've got to deal
with with this small army of vampires
that are in basically the entryway and
while our heroes are you know they're
they're formidable this seems like a
tall order but they managed to show them
pulling off stuff that makes you buy
okay yeah they can handle themselves but
not in a way that makes the vampires
feel weaker or makes the heroes feel
over probably just makes you go dang
they're good but then they go up against
Dracula and he just starts tossing them
around and shrugging off their attacks
is like oh dang okay now it's real and
and but you know as much as I love the
action in that episode especially for
the action was my favorite the lot of
the other stuff going on is pretty cool
too there's a surprising amount of
intrigue there's sort of
almost like poor man's a game of Thrones
kind of machinations going on among the
vampires in sort of Dracula's war
council in his and his declared war to
wipe humans off the face of the earth
cuz he's pissed although there's more to
Dracula than that - I was at Graham
McTavish does great work voicing him
actually all the voices are really good
but graham mctavish as Dracula I think
is actually the highlight but all of
them are good
I'm Trevor Belmonts good now the cards
good and I'm trying to think who the
they had they had Peter Stormare as as a
vampire called godhand
I'm sorry God godsend got hand I've lost
it now but he what her whatever it was
like you can't mistake that guy's voice
if you've ever seen him and he's like
and he doesn't stop sounding weird but
boy it works
so the all the voice work is good and is
solid but what I liked about Dracula is
there was a surprising amount of depth
and characterization to him because
basically all we got for setup previous
season was humans killed his wife who
was a human and now he's pissed and now
he's got to kill people we get a bit
more than that we get a closer look at
exactly how much losing his wife broke
him because what you realize as it goes
long and I and I to give credit I feel
like - Warren Ellis who was the writer
on these for this is that this is laid
out pretty clear clearly but it's never
said blatantly which is that what his
wife did for him was have him find value
and things other than what he'd been
taking his joy from before which was
massacres and bloodletting and revenge
and and all that stuff but she showed
him value and other things all filtered
through her and her love of humanity of
life of the world and then when he lost
her he lost that but also quickly
realized he can't
go back to what he what he can't just
become the monster he was again cuz his
heart's not in it anymore because she
showed him another way but his tethered
to that other way is gone so he's really
got nothing left he wants humans to die
for what they did to him but as another
character puts it he wants you mister
die he doesn't care how he just doesn't
he he doesn't have the energy or the
heart in it to care about how this
happens he just wants it done yet at the
same time it is also made very clear
this makes him no less dangerous
especially when you know the fight that
I mentioned happens some other stuff is
a bit more spoilery I think mentioning
that the heroes actually fight Dracula I
don't feel like that's a spoiler it's
what the whole thing to build me towards
so i'll more spoilery stuff if i feel
the need to talk about it at all I'll
save it for a little bit later but yeah
I like the the pacing and the intrigue
and there's a couple of characters who
are really interesting there's a couple
of human characters who work for Dracula
and they're there they have command of
magics that basically allow them to help
build his army by taking dead things and
molding them into these new sort of
creatures of the night - and to serve
Him so what I like especially about all
that is there is a not too much there's
just enough background and flashback in
information given to us about these two
humans to make us understand why human
beings would not only serve Dracula but
serve Dracula in a war against the human
race and in addition to that be able to
have different believable motives for
each of these - that's really cool again
I I mean I like Warren Ellis anyways but
I feel like that that's his influence
again is the the easy way to do this
would have been to just have these two
people who basically are
there might as well be identical you
know they have a similar background
similar reasons to be doing this but no
he came up with two completely separate
completely different backgrounds
histories and motives for them to be
doing this same thing that they're both
doing and I really liked that I thought
that was pretty cool oh there's a
there's a female vampire named Camilla
who is who is interesting she is very
opportunistic very nobody should trust
her and kind of everybody knows that but
at the same time she's really good at
enticing people by laying out well look
this is all I want and it would benefit
you too and there and pretty much again
they pretty much everybody knows and
they're like you're doing this to give
something you want out of it but it is
probably gonna help me too or you made a
case that look that lines up with what
I'm after so well that I'm gonna go
along with this even though I know it's
benefiting you she's just really good at
that which again pretty cool like no
real complaints about the season at all
I had an absolute blast my complaints
are nitpicky like I said a little more
creature variety would have been nice
the overall thing is paced pretty well
but if you plan to not binge through and
just watch another episode of the time
not sure why you would but if you were
to plan to do that it's probably not the
smoothest watching experience doing that
doing it that way even though being
animated it is quite violent not for the
young ones and even beyond the violence
there is also some language in it but
you know you make your own call on that
as far as your your own sensibilities go
I really I'm really loved binging
through this in the lead-up to Halloween
that was that was a good time I I'm
talking a couple of spoilers real quick
so I'm you know I liked it a lot if you
like this kind of animation go for it if
you haven't seen it already so took a
couple of spoilers now in three two one
I was surprised that Dracula died but I
really did like what made him stop
attacking as he just ends up with
Alucard and Alucard's childhood room and
it just kind of washes over him what it
is he's doing that he's on the verge of
killing his son the last remnant of the
woman he loved but not just that not
just that he reminds him of his wife but
that he has his he has his own wonderful
memories with this child and he shares
some of them you know we painted this
room together which honestly that's an
easy way to get to to me because I
helped paint my daughter from twice so
you know that but that that really rang
true for me and that they bring a
surprising amount of motion out of out
of the the end of all that and like I
said it helped that they had built
I feel Dracula's character really well
in terms of expressing how he was doing
was embarking on this revenge quest
almost mechanically like his heart
wasn't in it but he was gonna do it cuz
what else was he gonna do at this point
and it's it's really just well done I
got I also like that Trevor and oh god I
have lost her name which hard to think
of it earlier but the magician the
wizard whatever she is that they go up
together as much as it annoys me how
blatantly hinted at the potential
romantic entanglement of them is I
appreciate the fact that neither one of
them said I love you and they didn't
share a kiss honestly that that's a
minor thing but I hate those sorts of oh
well everything's fine now now these two
aren't together why I hate that so much
that just not having a 100% confirmed is
enough for me to go okay thank you and
in terms of like they laid enough
strands for to be able to pick up for
third season obviously we've got both of
the humans who you know who are in
different situations with different
agendas and I think there it is more
than cable
of bringing dracula back i mean the game
series has brought dracula back for
basically every game he dies at the end
of pretty much every game and then he
comes back that's what he does i would i
will be slightly cautious if they go
that route though because it really does
feel like it felt like the completion of
his story in a lot of ways because they
did such a magnificent job of not just
making him the end boss but make him a
character in his own right so yeah i i
really i do hope there is a third season
like I've seen initial rumors for I'm
excited to see it I loved this I'm
probably once I catch up on some other
stuff I'm probably gonna watch it again
a really good time
so Castlevania season two have you seen
it what did you think about it whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it
plus there's a whole bunch of stuff you
can do because there's buttons and
there's links down there including a
link to my patreon you know if you feel
like supporting me that way that'd be
awesome but if you don't don't sweat it
because at the end of the day folks you
are the council and I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]